how's go razzmataz period impact gonna
be a little quiet because there's people
sleeping I've been away the entire day
so I didn't have time to shoot this but
I'm so excited I do want to want for
spoilers as always if you haven't played
it yourself or I definitely recommend
doing it this game is really about
creating your own story after all so
this is the one that we shared together
baby baby boo that is you hello who I
why can I never write stories used to be
so simple we had a beginning middle and
an end
how else were they gone so we moved to
this office everything's gotten so
confused now look I didn't kill anyone
and I'm supposed to just believe you
know okay now he's rhyming I just want
you to be careful I almost lost you once
I'm not yours to lose I'm not going to
be an errand girl for crane anymore she
looks like oh it's
her sister Lily she was hooking to pay
down debt eventually the only people she
owed were at her work you know that
[ __ ] Club the puddin and pie my name
is Marisa
well Marisa I've got some questions the
open arms oh my god
what is it ah its crane
okay so who are the hell the snow remind
me so gay my job who is it
oh Jesus Christ is bothering me so much
what game that I played recently with a
girl she reminds me of the Elisabeth
Rohm BioShock Infinite that's it that's
it okay so we left off with that a lot
of [ __ ] happening
I don't remember I'll kill him
yeah yeah I'll tell him I'm a bar crane
oh god you think you know a person baby
you have to tell her I know yeah [ __ ]
betrayal man what's going on what did
you find up there crazy killer
what a kebab crane how do you know
because I have evidence
no big be calm down oh [ __ ] don't do it
everything's going to be fine okay it's
going to be fine someone please explain
this to me
perverted little [ __ ] might be after
snow I need to find her way No
okay it's it's going to be okay oh where
did you see her last
did she say where she was going she took
Holly to the business office to prepare
for the funeral Lilly's funeral yeah how
do you know I was just at the trip truck
and I heard gren telling some folks
about a funeral at the Buckingham fringe
trap are you drinking
right now they were on their way out
those two big be Aloha they both are
hiding [ __ ] from each other
why is she gonna do what snows snows
been through a lot they are things she
doesn't talk about just please be
careful when you tell her and you should
tell her but what are you trying to say
yeah how you felt when you saw that
picture well that's going to be much
worse for her just remember that
well I mean she doesn't have to see the
picture it's like two plus two it's [ __ ]
I got an achievement for a little lady
clicking four times score I was I was
gonna say is I really love this I love
this game it's so cool so we are in
Buckingham bridge and we're gonna [ __ ]
crane that little ass I don't understand
why he's not more in a hurry he seems
more of like a hey I'm gonna snoop
around and [ __ ] they're having the
funeral yeah that's probably a good idea
to not just rush in and [ __ ] okay
she seems fine
if you're here then you were part of a
very special circle people she trusted I
can't eat the rock cared for no way
I won't offend you by claiming one day
that that the pain of losing Lilly will
ever subside I know as well as you that
it will never subside but I also know
that that the memory of Lilly will
sustain as well and it will in time
equal in strength to our mourning her
loss what am I supposed to do then that
spirit that I'd like to talk about let's
look here all been so grateful to share
with Skyrim helmet what are you doing
here how she could be stubborn no you
will never die from indirection Tommy
too tedious she carried a torch for the
I sweetheart
for tradition for everything the
attachment tree and most of all it seems
how Lily love that [ __ ] is snow talking
about miss worrying about him I'll miss
you [ __ ] around I'll miss you good
times
oh why am i sniffing around in this [ __ ]
I'm just doing it because I don't want
to interrupt are we done
a moment of silence Jesus how long are
they gonna make me wait I don't want to
be disrespectful but at the same time
I'm not patient enough okay
is everything okay no not you Holly its
he wasn't [ __ ] invited Holly wait
he has no right to be here come on after
what he did I don't want trouble
look Holly not here to start trouble you
throw my sister down the witching well
and you have the nerve to show your face
here after you lie and say you'll check
first Holly wait that was crane just
crane yeah disposed of Lily's body
before Big B could do anything about it
I'm telling you the truth don't cover
for him but this genuinely wasn't his
fault you can't tell me Big B gives us
[ __ ] about this cranes of Prague that's
not important
um sorry I didn't know I guess I didn't
know he put her down the witching well
baby cares home got the right one
he's trying to help yeah sure he has a
very good reason for being here but this
one isn't on him
why are you here anyway and don't say
it's cuz you care about this everything
ok I'm here let's take let's talk to
snow first we can't just drop a bomb
know at a Funeral really yes
Holly this is serious okay okay look big
me and I are going to have a little chat
far away from the ceremony all right
look Holly I know how this must know you
don't know how this must feel you have
no idea
God don't [ __ ] anything up don't bother
anybody and when the first sign of
trouble comes and it will come because
you're a goddamn walking trap door
I thought you the [ __ ] out of here you
hear me I just want to get Lilly's
killer Holly nothing more yeah let's
discontinue ok yeah come on such total
[ __ ] [ __ ] let's go Holly it's
your turn to talk
huh well I went better than expected
surprised he didn't say anything nice
place for a funeral
this better be wildly important it's
been hard enough making a connection
with these people when you pull this
kind of stuff it just resets the clock
crane murdered Lily what I followed a
lead to this [ __ ] Motel the open
arms Greene had a room there and he's
been taking prostitutes or the very
least Lily and making her look like you
well he was you know that face taste ed
was covered in blood I know it was him
this is I don't even know what to say
right now I really don't
I'm just trying everything I can right
now to not picture it
I'm sorry snow and I'm sorry I had to be
the one to tell you you're sure this is
what happened this is what he's been
doing because please beg me don't
confuse things the posing crane would be
the next step and if we get this wrong I
mean more than our jobs
crane has been taking photos no lots of
photos photos that show him he's been
recording his visits with Lily see I
don't have to show them but she can know
that I have evidence let's go back to
the business office
I doubt cranes there at this hour but we
need to talk and this isn't the place
it's no Marisa what is it I'm sorry but
Holly's asking for you I'm the burn yes
everyone who spoke should really be
present for this part she's kind of
distraught you're not leaving yet are
you she can stay yeah I don't mean to be
um no I understand no I get it
take your time it won't take long I
don't see how it would affect anything
so I mean we can just let it do our
thing and how'd it go at the motel Oh
made anything I think it was very good
and yes thank you I did it helped a lot
Thanks Nerissa kind of name is that
coming isn't it written I'm sorry
is there is a real name I thought it was
Marissa with an Mamma Mia calm you know
oh [ __ ] how the hell know how this goes
the first thing in a visit you say how
do you do how do you do I told you to
run but it won't do any good
just make it more fun for me what are
you dreaming about you ain't a fast
enough pup to prevent me from emptying
both barrels to Snow White's face over
there I'm still hurting you know from
our talk in the cell in all be honest
I'd love nothing more than to carve a
sweet poem right into your face for the
suffering you've caused me but I am a
professional and we're here for a job
will snip to the chase for all sakes
a little bird told us at you're fit to
go after crane and you see we have an
interest in that particular boy so you
leave crane alone then we leave
just take a little vacation it's all
don't even have to go anywhere just sit
in your office and whistle to heaven for
a few short days you have three seconds
to [ __ ] off before this goes to a place
you don't want it to run a fight oh yeah
must stop watch on me
so what's it gonna be we have a deal you
leave crane alone and we leave you to
yours ah brother speak your mind fastly
now what's it gonna be
just don't hurt anyone d that don't
sound like a yes to me
yeah to do things the fun way
Oh ladies gentlemen invertebrates please
rest easy this is not the hell is going
on what's happening
very sorry to impose but we only had a
deal to work out with big knee and we
run happy to report that things did not
go as smoothly as planned
Big B what is he talking about I don't
know I'm not to date any of your deal
they want me to leave crane alone crane
oh now you shouldn't have done that old
boy really that wasn't right telling
everyone our dealings oh yeah I know she
was gonna do that
how did I tell you Oh should I say Holly
ah
oh honey so I know here under fight it
you think you can just [ __ ] interrupt
will ease feel wrong calm down darling
it was just a simple business
transaction who [ __ ] freaks are not
getting away with this Holly don't move
oh [ __ ] I think I uh lady love things
that don't have to turn sloppy calm down
huh lay down Holly and let's spare all
the fuss it's just a dead hole oh we did
not just say that
he didn't oh come on I got it done well
I got it too [ __ ] ha ha
god you're fat hey want a kiss to bat
okay
oh come on is everyone gonna die oh it
looks like it no I knew that was gonna
happen
this [ __ ] tragic man no double
funeral baby
it's only that's I know what up what up
went up why aren't you dancing to a girl
why are you dancing this cuz I do it
better you jealous now haters you can't
do this this is me touching your nips
very gently very softly ever so tender
I'm sorry I don't know it's crazy
it feels so weird like going back since
you haven't played this in like what is
it a month or something like that it's
all it feels really nostalgic in a weird
way cuz you wait so long I don't know
it's awesome though I always really
loved going back to these and we're in
episode 3 let's play a little more I
really like the title of this one it's
it's pretty interesting have you
brothers watch me play the crook mile
that was fun I think heroes had fun
doing that I did as well as I could to
take out the Buckshot but there's still
some shards left embedded in your
shoulder the helmet I warm their way out
on their own but until they do you're
gonna be sore baby doctor Swinehart was
appointed Fabletown physician for a
reason it's okay
there's only one thing you have to take
away from all this take it easy
damn easy be take don't go looking for
any more fights what keep strain off
your heart and try and get some rest are
you okay yeah I'm good is she she's fine
baby I had everyone that got wounded
sent home holly refused to let me see
where she lived so I left her and
Grendel back at her bar with a dose of
juniper and spring water associates must
remember what I said the stitches won't
hold up if you continue to act like you
normally do everything in moderation and
eat more chicken your blood pressure's
to the proverbial roof taking it easy is
not really my thing doc oh so badass
whatever your thing is try make it work
better for you next time I like the dog
character is coming business office I
know I'll have to call you back
the town is starting to find out well
I'll leave you two to it then miss white
big bean the town is starting to find
out what the hell new book of fables
what so to recap I lost nothing magic
man uncover him at the open arms and
then he smashed it so we couldn't use it
ourselves to go after know this because
Bufton was drinking in the rafters not
about cover it
once he puts all the pieces back
together it'll be easy to catch cream so
I guess that's the plan currently just
wait for the mirror
I don't know that's the plan yeah wait
for the mirror it's all we have right
now what the hell is going on just I
don't know what the Tweedles get out of
this I don't know if cranes sent them I
don't know if he's not even using glue
he's gonna sound crazy but do you really
think crane did it oh god don't feel my
cars to him I get it but do you really
think he killed those women because it's
just it's incomprehensible to me from
what I saw at the open arms everything
points to crane murdering Lili
yeah what isn't adding up for me is
faith why would he kill her
it doesn't seem connected yeah it
doesn't make sense he's he was a
conniver a coward a liar and I'll always
hate him for that and I'll hate him for
how he held me in his thoughts today
murdering prostitutes
everything okay over there yes miss
white just cut myself on a piece of the
glass nothing to worry about
thanks for tonight by the way that could
have gone really terribly we do get res
hell yeah we did
I'm glad you were there I just feel bad
for Paula that I just want to get in
there time heals everything eventually
well I do feel at least I hope so for
her sake she's this really mean and
everybody huge let's be nice and ask you
a question it's kind of personal
and I don't want to offend you but after
tonight it's on my mind why what's on
your mind I shifted so much it's just
when stuff hits the fan like like it did
tonight it feels like before we came to
the city it feels kind of like home
what and I've heard it said that maybe
in some tiny little bottled up way deep
inside you kind of enjoy it okay I don't
understand boom wrong what she's talking
about
because it gives you an excuse to just
you know ah [ __ ] no I don't enjoy it are
you kidding me it's horrible what
happened tonight I wish it didn't happen
I shouldn't have said anything
forget that I did I don't understand she
meant me first I don't want him to enjoy
it guys we have a problem
what is it I can't finish the mirror
it's missing a piece now can what do you
mean missing a piece Oh it's pretty
obvious ah it's not here green must have
taken a shard with him I can't believe
this I can it seems pretty smart I'd
take something up after he smashed it
I'm sorry I didn't realize what it was
until now
the mirror can't work unless it's hole
well that's not entirely true
what why God chuffed Caen what we sit
around and wait until it mends itself we
have no idea how long that will take
we're just gonna have to do this the
hard way I'm just saying waiting is an
option no we can't depend on the mirror
all right how long will it take for the
mirror to reform just want to know for
months or years he had to have left
something that tells us where he's going
he's a neat freak but he was never
smart the mirror is ourselves I know
never mind that come help me look look
at that guy who hanged in the background
what the hell do you see that I'm too
much cray cray all right perfect time to
end this first episode hope you bros
enjoyed watching it would help me out a
lot if you leave a like it especially
since it's a new series it's pretty
awesome
thank you for watching breaths and i'll
see you tomorrow with a new one
stay awesome res love you